>> It's a true honor to have
Mike Jordan with us today.
Mike is a professor in
the Department of
EECS and Statistics
at UC Berkeley and he's been,
obviously as many of you know,
an energetic leader, I'd say,
at the intersection of statistics
and the visions put forth by
the founders of the areas
of AI and cybernetics
in terms of the possibilities
for computational intelligence.
He's worked in both theory and
in practical applications.
Some of the practical
work includes his efforts
in genetics and
signal processing,
information retrieval, we
all know about some of
the work there, and
natural language.
On the technical side, he's
made significant contributions
in probabilistic
graphical models,
Bayesian nonparametric
analyses, spectral methods,
kernel machines and applications
to distributing computing
systems among other areas.
Speaking of probabilistic
graphical models,
I have to say that
I first met Mike,
I was starting to think of
that when it was, it was
a great salient memory.
>> We both didn't have
gray hair at the time.
>> That's for sure. Mine turned
gray a couple of months ago,
I don't know about you.
But it was in Corvallis,
there was a a Bayesian
probabilistic graphical
model summer school
in Corvallis that
[inaudible] together.
Right. I taught one course.
But Mike was with
a student and we were
walking out at break,
it was a morning break,
and Michael was the most
engaged student in the room.
He walked out muttering,
'This stuff is incredible.
This stuff is incredible.'
I remember he said that,
'These probabilistic
graphical models are incredible.'
I guess it was one of
your early exposures,
but you were just like dry
kindling waiting to be
lit on fire at that moment
as he was outraged
to see that face.
Another comment he
once mentioned to me,
and maybe you can tell the group
this sexual story, he said that,
'You were doing X,'
and I think it was,
maybe it was stat somewhere,
and 'You had this
chance to go hang
out with Don Norman and
Ruppman and Dave Rumelhart.'
The picture you painted,
I think it was over
dinner one night,
is you were on
this out-of-control kayak
going over a waterfall and you
jumped and you grabbed
the branch to stop
what you were doing and
go in a new direction.
That's exactly how you
put it so maybe you
can tell us more about
my memory there.
Anyway, it's really
fabulous to have you here.
I didn't finish
your whole bio here
but let me just say
that Michael has
received many well-deserved
recognitions,
you can read about them
in the bio online.
Today, Mike's talking about
gradient-based optimization,
accelerated, non-convex,
and stochastic.
Take it away. Thanks.
>> All right. That maybe
the most idiosyncratic
introduction I've ever had.
I wish you could
just keep on going,
it was very entertaining.
So, I'm just going to dive in.
I'm a technical researcher
academic and I just work on
the next wave of things and
all of this buzz and hype,
I'm a little bit
problematic here.
It's hard to avoid,
but I did build
a little cottage in my garden
and there's no
Internet down there
so I mostly can avoid it.
But I was recently in Chin-
about a year ago in China,
and I'm in the men's room
and the people
behind me were talking about deep
learning in the
men's room and then,
in a random restaurant in China
and I'm going, 'Oh, man.'
I finally, this week, wrote
a book, the last week,
I wrote a little blog thing
to put up a few thoughts out
there, just laid them down.
I'm not on social media
at all but apparently,
it's what you call viral
so it was really a lot.
I will not just jump into
most of my interests.
I'm going to say
a little bit about
this broader picture
and obviously,
a lot of you know probably
even more about AI.
I'm not an AI researcher,
I'm a statistician,
so many of you,
with apologies, will
know more than me.
But I do think that
this word is unfortunate.
I think it's a great aspiration,
I think inherent to our
students. It was the aspiration
that we had computers
but can they be made to seem
intelligent in some way,
and I think it's still
an industry of aspiration.
Someone turn on the gain
a little bit here.
I'm getting feedback.
Am I only hearing it?
>> It's resonating.
>> It was resonating
high frequencies.
So, we don't have it
yet. We don't have it.
We don't know what
intelligence is, I think,
and all these neural nets are
things that are just taking
the data, mimicking intelligent.
I don't know if we're going
to have it anytime soon.
We don't need it, really,
for most things that-
So many cool things
we can do without
trying to figure out what it is.
Also, a lot of the
people who work on,
use the AI buzzword these days
where they used to learn
autonomous systems because then,
it's really intelligent,
because no one's
telling it what to do.
I think that's fine but it's
somewhat misguided, too.
Really, all of our toasters
should be networked together
and decisions should be
made not independently.
They should be made hard as
other decisions, and so on.
So, I think that AI is used
too much as just a wildcard,
you throw it in
whenever you need to.
I don't also watch television but
I gather that
Mark Zuckerberg went for
a Congress recently and I
gather that whenever he was asked
any kind of a
challenging question,
he'd say, 'Well, AI
will handle that.'
Apparently, I heard it
16 times in his talk.
So, there's a little
hubris there about
computer science saying
we resolve it and also,
let's break things and then
later fix them, and all that.
But when you use AI as
an intellectual wildcard,
that's just not responsible.
I just don't think
that our community
should be supporting that kind
of irresponsible dialogue.
So, I wish we weren't saying AI.
That's fine as an aspiration but,
already a machine
learning bothered
me because we had free area,
called statistics,
which is the same stuff.
That's so well, I lost
all those battles.
Let me skip over that slide.
So, in this blog, I said,
'Let's don't use
AI for everything.
Let's make some distinctions.'
There's some historical
ones that are still
relevant and then there's ones
that have to do with
what problems we
should be solving and
that's pretty clear on.
Let's call it human-imitative AI,
that's where it was
back in the origins.
That's what I have toyed in mind.
It's a great aspiration to
think about how do we get
this thing that we
know has intelligence
inside of a computer.
But really, then
the next few decades
came forward and I
don't think very much
progress was made on that.
We don't really have anything
like intelligence yet,
but we did have lots of pattern
recognition stuff and lots
of information retrieval stuff
and algorithms of all kinds.
I think it's mostly IA,
it's mostly augment
our intelligence.
So, search engines
augment our intelligence,
translation systems do,
and so on so forth.
Interacting with humans and not
replacing human
intelligence but making
it somehow more interesting and
more deep, that's
what's happened.
But also, I think what's happened
is this thing that's
often called Internet
of Things by people
from computer science.
That's just a limited
version of it.
The real bigger version
is the one that I think
most of us are used to, is that,
all around us, there's
a network of intelligence
where the system
behaves intelligently.
It gives us options
for transportation,
it gives us options
for medical care,
it gives us options for
financial services,
commerce and so on.
We want that overall system to
behave intelligently
and to do that,
you don't need
the individual nodes to be
intelligent agents at all.
You want the overall system
to be intelligent in
the context of
human aspirations and goals.
So, if we think about that,
this focus on vision and speech,
and NLP and robotics is
misplaced because you don't
need those for
these brand or goals.
Those are hard problems,
they're not solved at all to
this day and focusing on
one of them makes you not
focus on many of
the other problems
that are really important.
I just wrote down something I've
been interested in working on.
Some of them are classical AI
aspirations but many
of them are not.
So, I'm going to
talk a little bit
about multiple decision making.
If you're in the class
in the AI world,
you think about an agent
making a decision.
Then maybe you think
about a sequence of
decisions, that's
the reinforcement executive.
With the real world problems,
you make 100,000
decisions simultaneously
for the current medical city
or around the world,
or for the transportation
network or whatever.
How do you control
errors across those?
You can't treat each decision
independently and think of
about it as collective agents.
Also, I'm really used in
systems that don't
just have data flowing
around but use that data flow to
create markets and
to create value,
and make people be able to
enter into markets and get
things out of it other than
just having a platform
that they go to.
Uncertainty to this day is
still not talked about very
well by the
machine-learning people.
They don't seem to care
about it because they
just think there's
enough data that
there's no uncertainty,
and that's just wrong.
Because they didn't think about
domains were searched
or commerce,
where if you get
the wrong answers,
no one dies or no one's hurt,
no one's really inconvenienced.
But we're trying to roll
this out in worlds where
people do die and get
hurt and inconvenienced,
then uncertainty
matters critically.
You tell me some machine
learning algorithm analyzed
my genome and my current
physiological state
and says I need to have
a heart operation,
I'm going to say how
sure are you about that.
Should we get some more data?
What if this happened?
All the other things
around these systems.
Cloud Edge
interactions, if you're
going to really build something
like a self-driving car,
you need to be able to have local
intelligence that's fast and
you need to go up to the Cloud
for more computation,
you need to communicate.
You need to fix all of
the problems have
nothing to do with
human intelligence
but are critical.
Moreover, this
overall system will
have different kinds
of knowledge in
different cars and
it will have to get
transmitted and made accord,
those are the
interesting challenges.
Anyway, I could go on.
Provenance is one, the database
we will talk a lot about,
but I think this is
really critical.
You're going to measure data
at one place and one time
in one situation and it needs to
be used in another place, time,
and situation, and you've got to
record some information
that makes it
possible to move it from
one place another and have
some reliability
about doing that.
So, a lot of
my e-mail colleagues just
say, 'Well, that's boring.
That's not the exciting.'
Well, no, that was not boring.
That's what database people did,
they changed
the world by building
principles that you could build
reliable databases
and that allowed
the banking system to
develop, for example.
So, I'm still getting
a lot of feedback.
I don't know if that
can be turned down.
I don't know if you are
hearing it but I'm hearing
all those squeaky stuff.
Okay.
So, let's talk a little bit
about multiple decisions.
I'm going to go sum up
quickly through this
because they're both going to be
talk with some other stuff,
but I hope you are
all aware that there's a
field called statistics,
and studies things like, well,
if I'm making many,
many decisions, not just
one or a sequence of them.
Here's kind of your
classic little cartoon.
Someone says
jellybeans cause acne.
Someone says let's do an AB test.
So, I'm gonna take 100 people,
put 50 in the
jelly beans category
and 50 in the no jelly beans.
And six weeks later I look at
their skin and see if they
develop acne and one
condition of the other.
No high probability,
that didn't happen.
You say, no, that didn't cause,
jelly beans doesn't cause acne.
But then someone comes
back and says, "Well,
we got to look deeper.
There maybe a certain
color causes it."
So now they do
all the experiments for
all the different colors.
You know what happens is that,
at some point, by chance alone,
the people who already had
a bad skin condition get put
in the treatment and
everybody else in control.
And it looks like
by chance alone,
that green jelly beans
are linked to acne.
Then the scientists getting all
excited because this
is a surprising thing.
They publish it, the journals are
happy to publish it
because it's surprising
the journalists pick up on it
and everybody's
all excited about.
This is until all dies down.
All right. And so,
we're awash in this.
Yet, if it's just
journalism and so on and
health or diet, who cares?
But, if it's medicine and
finance and commerce and
things that really matter,
this really matters a whole lot.
So, how many of you all know
about false discovery rate
and just a sort of time?
Yeah. Everybody here good.
This is MS so that's a good sign.
So, if you take
a little two-by-two table
of classification table, 0101,
there's a certain ratio in that,
that's called the precision,
another one's called recall,
and other one is accuracy.
There's also another one, it's
called FDR, just in
that little table.
It's not a brand new
thing out of it.
But it happens to
be one that you can
aggregate across
multiple decisions and
get control over the overall
fractions of errors in that.
So, can you control FDR?
Well, starting with
Benjamini-Hochberg,
there was a line of research
that's been doing that,
and it is real important to know
about but it made
strong assumptions.
It assumed that you
had independence
and no logical constraints.
As time has gone on,
boy, I'm surprised.
>> Try with [inaudible]
>> Yeah.
I guess that's
the video also though.
>> I got the guy coming.
>> The guy is coming?
>> Yeah.
>> What about
the Gallup organization.
>> All right. If you're
using the video,
this is not going to help.
Okay. I'll just try to not use
high frequencies in my voice.
No freakiness.
>> Can I just turn
this thing off?
Is that okay? Would
the video still work?
>> [inaudible] video
>> Yeah. That's his video feed.
Is there a game?
>> I can't touch AB guys.
>> People have heard me
lately saying, there's
a grand AI challenges, the
killer AB wire wants to create
something.
>> Right.
I'll ignore it if you guys
will ignore it for a while.
>> [inaudible]
>> Okay.
>> Might help, yeah. That's
a good musicians fact.
So, there's been work on removing
these assumptions and this
is piece of publicity.
I don't want to get
this a separate talk,
but we've just written a paper
which I think is kind of
a very full version of
this you can now have
hypotheses or related by
a Directed Acyclic Graph.
So, we if this
hypothesis is true,
this must be or if there's
a logical constraints.
So if reject this one,
you must reject this one.
That's been allowed now.
More of it can be done
on an online matter,
that you can start rejecting
hypotheses or accepting.
Over time, I can stop
you at any moment and
your error fraction up
to that moment should
be under control.
So, there's a simple relevant,
simple algorithm that does
these kind of things.
Why am I holding this? All right.
But I also want to focus
on another side of
multiple decisions
as less discussed.
It is about load balancing,
and this is where economic ideas
I think are coming into play.
So, think about situations
where we're making
100,000 decisions,
like in a transportation system
or a medical system.
Now, if there's no
scarcity of resources,
it's not such a big deal.
But in real world, there's almost
always scarcity of resources.
So, let's think about
a recommendation system.
Amazon built one. You come in
and it recommends
maybe a movie to you,
and it does that by looking
at all the features and notes
about you and so on.
Now later that day,
someone else comes on the system
and a recommendation is
made to that person.
Those are independently
done, right?
Suppose it's the case
that you recommend
the same movie to everybody.
A hundred thousand people
came to your site,
99,000 got a certain
movie recommendation.
That's fine. There's no scarcity.
I can stream the same bits
to everybody.
All right? What if I recommend
the same book to everybody?
Well, it's a little bit
of a problem.
If 99,000 people order it,
it's going to be
a little bit of a problem.
But we're not yet in
the core of the problem.
The core of the problem is
something more like this.
What if I recommend the
same restaurant to everyone?
So tonight in Redmond,
if you all go out,
and your app says,
"We recommend this restaurant",
based on your profile
and all that,
my Poisson statistics, there's
going to be a good chance
that 400 people get
recommended same restaurant.
You although there, and
there's a line and
no one's happy.
No one's getting served.
How do you fix that?
Well, if you're a computer
science [inaudible] you say,
Zuckerberg-type person, you say,
well, we're just
better algorithms, AI.
Yeah. Well, no. That's
not going to really work.
We're not going to
be able to know how
to do that load balancing.
There's all kinds of
issues that would arise.
What if we figure out
the best path from
here to the airport and
we recommend that to you,
and to you, and to you, right?
Well, everybody are going on
the same street. All right?
Again, you might think, no
big deal. We can fix that.
Those are small problems,
right? But they really are.
So now, think about building
a financial service
and I'm going to roll
it out say in China
to 500 million people.
Because people have some
money and I'm going to
make recommendations to them.
This financial, everybody
should buy that stock.
Right? By Poisson statistics,
there's a good chance
I'm gonna recommend
a 100,000 people to
buy certain stock.
I'm going to
destabilize the market.
These aren't cartoons.
You can see that this
is really the core
of the problem.
Okay. So now, how
do you fix this?
Well, you bring in economics.
You don't just treat this
as a platform that you
build and do machine
learning on. All right?
You recognize that whenever
you made data-flow,
you can build on top of
that economic ideas. All right?
So, think about
the restaurant situation,
what you really need is
a two-way market, okay?
So you need that the people in
the restaurants have one app
and the people who
are the customers
have a different app, right?
The people on restaurants
say, "Tonight,
I have 50 seats open or
there's a wedding in there
but I got 50 seats open and I
prefer people from out of town,
and I prefer
young people whatever."
I have some policy, right?
So now, when I walk
out of the movie at
7:00 PM, my app says,
that restaurant and knows
about you and it makes
a 10 percent discount for
the next 10 minutes, all right?
Now look, that's great. I accept.
Now, the other app
has field one of the seats
in the restaurant.
There's now 49 seats left
and it keeps going
until it's full.
I mean, it's an open market.
All the other restaurant see
that that favorite
restaurant is now
full and they start making
their own offers saying,
big opportunity, I'll make
a 30 percent discount
and I'll fill my restaurant
tonight for the first time ever.
All right? So now data,
just by the connection of data,
you're able to build
a two-way market.
All right? You are ready to solve
the load balancing problem
which has gone, okay?
Plus, you'd be able
to make connections
between business and
consumers directly,
not between you as a
computer science platform
and business or you
and computer science platform
and the customer,
directly between them, and
you've created a market.
Now, if you want to take
your five percent cut,
you can make money off of that.
That's all good. All right?
Now, here's another example.
So I'm involved in a company
called United Masters.
I'm on their scientific
advisory board.
It's a fantastic [inaudible]
it's the people really in
the music business but kind
of on the musician side.
So, it's easier than ever to make
music people were making
really good music
on the weekends.
This is not their full time job
and upload it to SoundCloud.
Then, the streaming services
are getting that
music and people are
listening to it more
than ever before
but no money is flowing.
No one's making
money off of that,
and that's a problem because
people can't have that as a job.
There's a big loss of
opportunity that a market
would be able to create.
So, how do you fix that
while you create a market?
All right. So,
this particular company
is doing that in
the following way.
They partner with the people
who have the data-flow.
For any given budding musician,
you're not the top 100
that the record companies
had picked up on but the
next 100,000 or million.
They take each one of
them in and they collect
all the data of all the people
who've listening to them,
and then they reveal that
to them on a dashboard.
So all you can see a map of
California and I would see
all the cities this week,
how many people have
been listening to me
or of the whole US? All right?
A lot of these people,
they have a big listenership.
So if I learned for
example that for
some reason in Orlando, Florida
there's 10,000 people had
been listening to
me this past week,
somebody like them and
tell they're friends.
Then based on that data,
I would go give a concert and
I could maybe make $25,000.
If I do that three times during
the year, I have a salary.
I don't have to drive a taxi
during the week and make
music on the weekends.
I have a salary suddenly.
Moreover, there's a connection
now again between
the merchants and the consumer.
The musician now knows
who listens to him or
her. They can make
offers to them.
I'll play your
daughter's wedding for
$10,000 or you can come
backstage and so on.
So, I now have a market,
and I can price
things and compete
and have points and loyalty
programs and you name it.
Now, people can have jobs, right?
We don't have musicians who
have jobs mostly right now.
I know a lot of musicians
and none of them have jobs.
Except the top 100 like
Beyonce that are getting
promoted to death.
So, computer science can
be done to do that if you
partner with economics,
and data science data
is the thing that
glues it all together.
Okay. I think I'm going
to skip this other one.
It's another kind of
a business about economics.
Yeah, I think I'll skip this one.
Okay. So, I had a list of
challenges there and I picked
a couple that I just want to talk
about that brought
up some themes.
In sums, these are
really things that I'm
currently interested
in working on.
So, I don't have results
per se to talk about,
but I'm quite convinced
the results are going to come.
Let me talk a little bit about,
now turn to the core of what
I promised to talk about.
So, we're going to be linking
statistics and computer science.
So, I am really an academic.
I don't want to just do
this in an ad hoc way
and create something
that kind of works,
but I want to understand
the fundamental principles.
To go, I am particularly
in lower bounds
more and more
these days because that
strips away all the
inessential stuff
and lets you focus
on the essentials.
I don't think that
machine learning
has achieved what
people think it's
achieved that it
blended statistics
and computer science
in some deep way.
I think that borrowed
ideas from here,
there kind of put them
together willy-nilly,
but there's no
foundational principles
that have emerged by
bringing those two together.
We're missing those
foundational principles.
So in particular, data analysis
problems have a time budget.
So, you need to be able
to say something like,
well like in finance
it's microseconds,
search or Internet
it's milliseconds,
in medicine maybe it's hours.
But what there is
always time budget.
The idea that you control risk
under a time budget is not
familiar to either
statisticians or
computer scientists at
a theoretical level, okay?
So, how do we start to do that?
So, I think many of
us who work in
this more theoretical branch
the field think that
optimization has
provided the best help with this,
especially if you're
thinking about
lower bounds and
complexity results.
Computer science doesn't have
hardly any lower bounds and
mostly the ones that you
have are meaningless.
It's because the computer
science model is too strong.
Turing complexity is just too
strong that tried
to do everything,
when you do not everything
and we'd get
more meaningful bounds.
So, authorization tree
does exactly that.
So, it's provided
algorithms and insights.
Statistics also has a lot
of good lower bounds.
I mean, you've
heard of Cramer Rao
lower bound but there's
a lot of others
and they have been
very important for
this older field to progress.
So, taking statistics lower
bounds and matching them with
optimization lower bounds
is turning out
to be very productive.
Okay, moreover, used to be,
I learned optimization
in the 80s and it
was taught as a definished field.
There was simplex and gradient
and conjugate gradient,
it was just done.
There was software for all
of it and it was just done.
All right. That's turned
out to be completely wrong.
All the new problems
that we were getting and
plus the perspectives
that arose out of
the Soviet Union with
gradient-based
methods have really
changed everything. All right.
So in fact, those of us who
work on this are focussed on
really simple algorithms
that can work
in a computer
science scalable sense.
So, we will restrict
ourselves to gradients,
no Hessians at least for now.
That'll probably change.
We do stochastics because it's
cheaper and our data
is noisy anyway.
Then we work on acceleration
because the geometry matters.
Acceleration allows you to
bring in geometry and it
also allows you to achieve some
of the lower bounds that
I was referring to.
Then how these things
all interact in
a detailed way is what
most of us are working on.
I may acknowledge a
couple of people that
is Ge Huang who I
met this morning has
worked a lot on these things and
Chi Jin sitting in
the front is a student at
Berkeley who's the expert
and I'm going to be
talking about some of
his work, with many others.
This has been a topic
that I think is
the field of machine learning
is very very popular these days.
A lot you'll think
deep learning is everything and
I have nothing against
deep learning. It's great.
But at the same time,
there's been
just as much progress
have done more on
this theoretical wing
and it's less aware.
People here and other places
have been doing this.
Okay, so I learned from Chi
that the bad local minima,
which I thought were
the core problem
when he went to
non-convex problems,
are not so bad after all maybe,
at least in a wide class
of problems.
So, there's a lot of
architectures which in
the last few years
people have proved
have no local minima at all.
They have a single global optimum
and then a ring of
saddle points around that.
So, it's really saddle points
that are the problem.
You should think about
a saddle point as
a lot of directions that
you are coming down but
then they go back up
again and there's really
a precious few
directions allow you
to get out. All right.
Now, why is that a problem?
Well, in two three dimensions
it wouldn't be a problem,
but in 100,000 dimensions
it may be very very hard to
find that direction
leads you to get out.
It can take
a huge amount of time.
In fact, when you
train neural nets,
you see the error rate comes
down real fast and flattens
out and then you wait for
some indeterminate amount of time
and then it comes down again.
You're in a saddle point
and you're probably
hit a couple of
saddle points, right?
So, we need, if we're
going to really understand
anything about how long
it's going to take to
train these things and how
things get larger and larger,
we need something about
the dimension dependence.
So, not just rate of convergence,
the classical thing,
after how many iterations do you
need to be within
epsilon of the optimum,
but as a function of
dimension as well.
Okay, so there's
a saddle point in
two or three dimensions.
We're going to be
interested in how do you
escape it efficiently,
meaning efficient
computer science sense
and specifically getting
the dimension dependence.
Naively, you might think would
be exponentially have to
search all combinations
of directions, right?
So, this is work with Chi
and some others Rong Ge,
Sam Kakade was here in the city,
and Praneeth Netrapalli who
is at MSR, is that correct?
Yes and in India.
Okay, so here's a little bit
of background that led to
this particular line of work
that I want to focus on.
In joint work with
Jason Lee and others,
we were able to show
that gradient descent
asymptotically will never
end up in a saddle point,
for anyone's intuition but this
has been an open
problem actually.
For gradient flow, which is
the continuous version
of gradient descent,
it's the differential equation X
dot is equal to dot
minus the gradient.
That's been known for 100 years
based on Morse theory that it
asymptotically voids but
that's asymptotics and
has been open for
the gradient descent,
that us discretization
gradient flow.
So, that sounds good but then
there's a negative result,
with again Chi Jin and Simon Du,
that gradient descent can
take exponential time to
avoid saddle points, okay?
So, there's a class of functions
which aren't that weird,
where it does take
exponential time.
So, it's something
of a surprise that
Chi and some others
proved a theorem
in 2015 that showed that
if you add stochasticity
of a certain kind,
you go from exponential
data polynomial.
Now, that result still
left us a little bit
short of the explanation of why
gradient descent is so effective,
stochastic gradient so
effective, it's just polynomial.
It could be high degree
polynomial, okay?
So, the goal in this line
of work was to prove
a stronger theorem.
Okay, so let's get started.
Let's talk about
convex optimization.
F is convex.
Let's look at gradient descent.
There it is, go
down on a gradient.
It is a fact that you get
convergence to global minimum
under very, very weak conditions.
Moreover, more importantly
for this talk,
the number of iterations to
get there is independent
of the dimension.
That's less well and appreciated
and it's an amazing fact.
You can be at infinite dimensions
and the number of
iterations to get the
optimum is the same as if
you're in finite dimensions.
So, some caveats there but
that's basically true.
Now, let's go on beyond
convex problems.
Let's go to the non-convex world
that people like
Sebastian helped us get into.
So here, we can
have local maxima,
we can have saddle points
and local minima.
So, what can we say
about that world?
Okay, so first of
all, just briefly,
this is the list,
and it's probably gotten longer,
about non-convex problems that
have only approval but have
a single global optimum and they
have saddle points
is the problem.
So, an interesting list.
Doesn't include neural nets but
it includes lots of
other interesting and
important problems.
Okay, so let's just set
up the basics theory,
the classical case
for gradient case,
and then move on to
the non-convex case.
So, for the classical
convex case,
one talked about a simple
smoothness assumption
the gradient doesn't change much,
a minimal assumption
you can make.
Then you attempted to
prove that algorithm
would converge
to a first-order
stationary point.
So, that would be a point
where the gradient
is equal to zero,
classical stationary
point from calculus.
Then we put a little
epsilon ball around
that so that we can get a rate.
So, you could do it for
different values of epsilon.
You can talk about the rate at
which you're approaching
the optimum.
That's why the epsilon is there.
So, it's called the epsilon
first-order stationary point.
Here is an example
of a result due to
Nesterov which shows that
the convergence rate is
one over epsilon squared,
which is polynomial rate.
It says, if you want
a really small epsilon,
the number of iterations
is going to be
more. It's going to grow.
This is the initial
distance to the
optimum and that makes sense.
If you're far away,
you got to get there.
It's going to take
that amount of time.
There's your Lipschitz constant
and no dimension dependence.
That's the amazing thing about
this algorithm,
no dimension dependence.
Okay, what about
going beyond that.
So, let's go now to
the non-convex case.
So first-order
stationary is no longer
an appropriate criterion because
saddle points are
first-order stationary.
We don't want to
hit saddle points.
So, we need to go beyond that.
Let's define a notion of
secondary stationarity,
where the gradient is again
zero or you put a ball
around that to get a rate.
The minimum eigenvalue is
greater or equal to zero,
but again you let a little slope,
you let it go slightly negative
so you can get a rate.
This is a particular
parameterization
of that amount of negativity.
That row is a Lipschitz constant.
Now, for the Hessian, we need
to make a little smoother
assumption also in the Hessian,
because the Hessian
changes wildly.
You're not going to be
able to converge out
of a saddle point.
Okay, so this is the original
paper doing this.
There has been
some work since then,
but this is a minimal algorithm,
a simple algorithm that can
be analyzed theoretically.
So, it's just gradient
descent but
from time to time
has sporadically,
you add uniform noise
from a ball around
your current iterate.
You do that when
the gradient is small,
but you don't do
it too frequently.
There's a parameter T
which says you only
do it once every T steps.
This can be removed.
The particular choice of
uniform ball is not essential,
but the basic idea
of having to have
stochasticity is
certainly necessary.
We saw the exponential
rate before.
This is just an example
of an algorithm
can be analyzed
relatively simply.
Okay, so here is the theorem
from this work by Chi Jin et al.
It saw the number of
iterations done in
all these assumptions to find
a second-order stationary point
now, not first order.
It looks exactly the same
as the Nesterov result.
So, one over epsilon squared
distance the optimum
Lipschitz constant.
The only difference is that
little twiddle right there,
which is standard theoreticians
trick for hiding
the dimension dependence.
But we don't want to hide
So, the whole point of
this talk is that we're
being honest about
it and there it is.
It's polylogarithmic
in dimension.
So, it is not polynomial.
It's way better than that.
It's logarithmic
effectively, okay?
That four is probably
an artifact of
a predictor proof technique,
but it's probably logarithmic as
the truth but it is logarithmic.
So, that I think
is perhaps one of
the first convincing reasons
why you should think stochastic
gradient should work well in
high dimensions because
its dimension dependence
is so favorable.
The proof technique
here basically involves in
some sense some
difference in geometry.
Around saddle point there is
a region that has
seen its variants.
So, there is a region where if
you're in that region, it's
hard to get out of it.
The flow due to
the negative eigenvalue
doesn't hit you fast enough,
and you're sort of
stuck for a long time.
So, you need to measure
the width of this region,
and this paper used
a coupling technique
from probability theory.
It's said, I don't
know that width
but I started
two coupled diffusions.
They're width r apart and
then vary r until you get to
phase transitions when they
start to fly apart
from each other.
That point you know the width.
So, you don't just
have to do kind
of replace it with a flat slab,
which had been done in
the previous work to get
the polynomial dependence and
this logarithm that comes
out of that argument.
Okay.
All right. So, with
that as background,
there's a few key ideas
that emerged in this,
that are going to be allowing
us to look at some other problem.
So, first of all, I
haven't said anything
yet about acceleration.
Again, there're
some real experts in the room,
and they will tell you
accelerations pretty important
if you're a theoretician.
It adds momentum to the problem,
it allows you to achieve
some of these Oracle rates,
and we want to
bring it into contact
with these other ideas.
So, there's been an open problem.
If I'm arriving at a saddle
point is it possible to kind of
blase pass the saddle point
because of the
momentum I built up?
Or is momentum not independent?
So, it did not help me
with saddle points.
Can we use other kinds
of stochastic
models not just this one?
If we go to kind of fold
stochastic models we talk about
diffusions and how the diffusions
interact with the kind of
this convex and
non-convex geometry.
So, all kinds of new problems
we'll start to look at.
In my group, we have
gotten a lot of help by
thinking about
these problems not in
discrete time but
in continuous time.
So, that's probably
the big message
of my talk, it's that,
if you thought you could avoid
differential equations and
you went into computer science to
avoid differential equations,
I'm sorry to tell
you you're going to
have to learn about
differential equations.
All right. Now, why? Well, we're
trying to develop
fast algorithms,
and algorithms we know
how fast they can be,
and what we want to analyze
what's the fastest rate?
So, what does it mean to have
the speed of an algorithm?
If I'm just hopping along
some discrete points,
what does it mean to hop faster
on those discrete points?
Well, it means you've
embedded the problem in
a continuum of time somehow.
All right.
If you go to bed the problem
of continuum of time,
you have to start talking
about differential equations.
So, this line of
work has done that.
It's gone pretty
far at this point.
So, I'll tell you a little bit
about Variational,
Hamiltonian Symplectic
Perspectives.
Andrew Wibisono is now
a postdoc but he was
a student with me,
and Ashia is still the student
with me one more year.
They played a major role
in developing this work,
the Variational,
Hamiltonian framework.
Then Ashia has gone
quite a bit further with
Lyapunov perspectives
on all of this stuff.
Then on the Symplectic work,
Mike Betancourt has joined us
from Colombia to help out.
So, this is about embedding
optimization problems
in continuous time,
and once you've done that,
you learn about why
algorithms would behave
certain ways in discrete time.
There's going to be phase
transitions happening only in
continuous time that you
would never have seen
just in discrete time.
Or with great labor.
So, let me say
something a little bit,
kind of grandiose sounding,
but if you look at
the fields that are
mathematically the most mature,
they make serious usage
of the fundamental
theorem of calculus.
There are some differentials,
and there's also some integrals.
All right. Fields that aren't so
mathematically surely, I
picked one or the other.
So, physics is
the poster child for this,
Newton wrote down
F equals MA which
is laws of nature
using derivatives.
So, differential
equation, and then
LeBrons came around about
100 years later and said,
"I can rewrite all that physics
using integrals."
I'm going to integrate
an energy and then moreover
he introduced optimization.
I'm going to optimize
the integral of
the energy and I will get
out the same physics.
Probability theory is full of
this telegram smart paths or
this Feynman diagrams
or this statistics
as the Laplace expansions,
saddlepoint expansions.
So, anyway, all of this is
really just fundamental from
calculus used in elaborated ways.
The numerical disciplines
also finite element analysis,
is you take a PDE and
you've just created
little patches using integrals
and relate those integrals
to each other.
Monte Carlo is trying to
do integration by using
derivatives inside of
the integral, and so on.
So, you can now ask
about optimization is.
Is it one of these mature fields?
As I alluded to earlier,
it was kind of thought
of as done.
So, it's not done,
and in particular, it's only
focused on differentiation.
You open up paper after paper,
and there's
all these derivatives,
and there's inequalities
based on the derivatives,
but there's almost
never an integral sign.
Just some Taylor expansion of
something you're ignoring,
but otherwise it's not really
fundamentally part of the field.
So, I would argue that
field is not mature yet.
So, let's now again
fix ideas by looking
at a simple situation.
Let's talk about
convex optimization
again, smooth convex
optimization.
Here's gradient descent again.
Now, here's a new fact,
that if you're a statistician,
otherwise you might not.
It's that not only does
this algorithm have
this specific convergence rate
for a particular function,
over the entire class
of convex functions,
it has a convergence rate.
That rate is here.
So, this is the worst case rate.
It says that after k
steps have gone by,
you're within one over k order,
one over k of the optimum.
So, it's a convergence rate for
the transit complexity
results really.
So, once that was known,
and it's probably been
a few decades now.
The Russian school our
[inaudible] asks a
very interesting question.
They said, is there a general
complexity result here?
Is there a lower bound for
this class of algorithms?
Now, what does that mean?
Well, first of all,
he had to think about
what kind of computer am I
talking about to
get a lower bound.
So, when we look at
all possible algorithms,
we'd like to talk
about the platform.
If you talked about
Turing complexity
this point, that wouldn't
be very helpful.
The lower boundary is a zero.
You just look at
the description of
the function and
figure out the answer.
So, it had to be more
restricted to family,
and so he said, "Well,
I'm just going to
allow you to look
at the gradient,
and I'm going to
allow you to keep
all previous gradients and
your updates must be
in the linear span of
all previous gradients."
So, it's a very powerful machine
but it's not Turing-complete,
but you can make
progress with it.
So, after doing that he
said, "In this family,
for a smooth convex functions,
what's the best you can do?"
He proved that it was
one over k squared.
It was faster than
gradient descent.
So, there was an open
period of time where
no one knew whether it was
an algorithm that could
be gradient descent
and arrive at that lower bound.
So, it was something of
a surprise when Yuri Nesterov in
1983 wrote down this algorithm
which has got two pieces
instead of just one,
and it achieves the lower bound
of one over k squared.
So, it's kind of
some amazing facts about,
well, first of all,
it is kind of a gradient
descent thing, the y-variable.
There's two variables now,
y is using the x gradient,
and then the new x is kind
of a linear combination
of the previous two y's.
So, it's got this heavy ball
or momentum flavor,
there's like a little bit
of implicit here,
but it's a bit of a mystery
where this comes from,
but it's no mystery that
it does achieve this rate.
That's really amazing.
Moreover, one of the mysteries
is that this thing is
not a descent algorithm,
it can go down and then go
back up, and go back down again.
That seems strange if
you're trying to get
down to the bottom
as fast as possible.
Gradient ascent is
the steepest descent.
So, how can you beat it?
That you really are
beating it. All right.
So, again, I think it's
you got to go into
continuous time to
understand this.
So, let's start with going into
continuous time with
gradient descent.
So, here's the
gradient flow widely
studied by the mathematician
still to this day.
You can analyze the rate of
convergence of that
for convex functions.
The rate is one over t,
corresponding to one over k for
gradient descent. All right.
So, now you can
ask, what if I take
the Nesterov equation
which has one over k
squared and I look at the- I take
the step size as zero and get
out a differential equation?
You will get out one.
Here's what you get out.
This was done by Su,
Boyd and Candes.
You can analyze the rate of this,
and it is one over t squared.
It's interesting equation, it's
second order and no surprise
because you had two equations.
There's a mysterious three here,
and there's a damping term.
There it is, there is
the differential equation
for Nesterov. All right.
So, we looked at this and I
said that's an interesting
differential equation,
but where does that come from?
Why is that the best
differential equation?
In what sense- why they're
giving you the optimal result?
Okay. So, it's a little bit like
Lagrange looking at F equals MA,
and saying that's a great
differential equation,
but why that
differential equation?
Where's it coming from?
Is there energy
principle allows us
to derive that differential
equation from some principle?
Okay. So, that's
what we worked on,
and we have a paper about
a year and a half ago in PNAS.
I'm just going to
show you the answer.
This is our answer.
Our answer was to write down
the following Lagrangian.
So, it's in continuous time.
The alphas, betas, and gammas
are not the important part,
they're just degrees
of freedom that
give you a family of algorithms
on just one algorithm.
We'll set them in
particular ways.
So, that just time scalings.
The important part is
this thing right here,
which is called a
Bregman divergence.
Hopefully most of you
know what that is.
Here's the math of Bregman
version, here's the picture.
You're trying to measure
distance between x and y,
you do that by writing down
an auxiliary function h,
and you take the linear
approximation of h at x,
and you look at
the discrepancy at
y so that red amount there,
is the Bregman divergence.
It measures the distance on
the X-axis by using
this vertical distance.
If h is quadratic,
this just becomes Euclidean
distance in the x and y.
This is just a variational way of
writing a Euclidean distance.
But h could be logarithmic and
all sorts of other things
are possible. All right.
So, we're going to
use the Bregman
divergences in a novel way.
We're going measured
the Bregman divergence
between x where we are now,
and x plus a time scaled x dot.
So, it's kind of
a little bit of I got
elasticity if you will,
or energy along
the direction of the flow.
So, think in fact that this
is like a kinetic energy,
and then we take a time
scaled version of the function,
we're going downhill and
that's like a potential.
We want to go down on that.
So, this is like a kinetic
minus a potential, or Lagrangian.
Moreover, if you
set h to quadratic,
this thing reduces to
one half x.squared.
So, it literally becomes
the classical kinetic energy,
and this is literally Lagrangian.
It's a time varying
Lagrangian because
we want not just
oscillate around,
we want to arrive at the- we want
to end up at the optimum.
Okay. So, what do you
do with Lagrangians?
Well, you put them
inside of an integral,
and you optimize over paths.
All right, and that's
what we do here.
So, we put it inside
of an integral,
and then, we optimize over paths.
So, now we'll compute
some path and
we'll compute a dynamics
along that path.
All right? The way you get all
that is by a
differential equation.
How do you get that
differential equation?
Well, you set all the partial
order is equal to zero,
for essentially that,
the continuous time
version of that,
that's called the
Euler-Lagrange equation.
So, I just tip that object
with some derivatives,
and I will pop a differential
equation and I will do it,
and start master
differential equation.
Here it is, I claim
this describes
a vast family of accelerated
methods in continuous time.
It has a dex double dot,
it's got a damping term,
and it's got a bunch of
geometry right here.
If you set H to quadratic,
and if you set Alpha and
Beta as logarithmic in T,
then this whole thing reduces to
that Suit Boyden Canada's
differential equation
with a three over t and all that.
But this also gives you
a whole bunch of others,
mirror to sense acceleration,
cubic retadoras
Newton acceleration
and a whole bunch of others.
So, in some sense it is capturing
this family in continuous time.
All right, next question, does
it give me anything more?
Does it, for example, give
you convergence rate?
Okay. Because usually
convergence rates
are case-by-case basis,
it sets couple of pages of
Cauchy-Schwarz and
Jensen's inequality, and so on.
So, it's a pleasant surprise,
and it's helped us
feel that we're on
the right path with
this line of work,
that there's a one line proof
of convergence.
The convergence rate is big O
of e to the minus Beta T,
where Beta T is a degree
of freedom you get a set.
Talk about that in a minute.
The proof is just you write
down a Lyapunov function,
again using the
Bregman divergence,
you take it's
first time derivative
and you ask that be negative.
That happens if and
only if this is true.
So, there you get the convergence
right once and for all.
Okay. Again, Ashia has
worked a lot on
the Lyapunov function.
She's not only worked
with this one but also
done the mapping between
discrete and continuous
time Lyapunov functions,
kind of getting rid of
the Nesterov estimating
sequenced techniques if
you were replacing them.
Okay. Now, this point start
to become interesting,
because this suggests
that you can
achieve any rate you
want to achieve.
I said Beta T was
a degree of freedom.
Okay. So, suppose that
I know a little bit about
convex optimization.
I don't expect to get
an expression array.
That seems not plausible.
Okay. So, I'm going
to be not ambitious,
I'm going to set
Beta of T to say,
logarithm of T. Then,
the logarithmic it kills
the expansion I get one over
T. I know the gradient flow
achieves that.
All right. So, let's see
if I would recover gradient flow.
Well, I just take
that definition of Beta,
I plug it back into the
Euler-Lagrange equation,
or my master
differential equation,
and I solve it I
get gradient flow.
Okay, now here comes along and he
says I want to go faster,
I'm gonna set Beta
T to two log T. So,
I get one over T squared.
He puts that in the
Euler-Lagrange equation,
it delivers that Nesterov
accelerated nothing.
Okay. No derivation,
just the math does it.
She gets to says, why don't
we go faster I want T cubed.
So, he puts in three log T
and he actually
gets out of differential
equation that it converges rate
to one over T cubed.
Okay. G1 comes on and says,
no I'm going to do
it exponentially.
Look the math of permits
it. So, I'm going to do it.
So, I'm going to set Beta
of T is just equal to
T. He will do that,
he will get an Euler-Lagrange
equation and he will get
a differential equation
and in continuous time,
he will flow along at
that rate, no problem.
Okay. Now here's
what's interesting,
all four of us will
go along exactly
the same path, right?
It's just that one of us
will go slowly on that path,
one will go faster, and
he will zip right along.
So, in continuous time,
acceleration is not the rate
that's interesting,
it's the path.
It's about this
particular geometry of
this path, the global geometry.
Okay. The path is made and
why is that happening?
Well, because this Lagrangian
is co-variant as
the differential geo-G
operator, that's why.
Okay. Now, so this actual speed
big O just means,
we're just using
different clocks.
Okay. Who cares?
He uses a slow clock, I use
the fast clocks it's on.
He is the superfast clock.
So, it's like Einstein says,
"The clock actually
doesn't matter.
It's not interesting here."
What is that she's a path.
Now, but here's where it
finally gets really
interesting which is that,
Eric and me and she will
go into these rates,
we know that we can achieve ours,
GJin is being a
little more ambitious
but he can actually
achieve one over T cubed,
that's a discovery here.
He can't, in the sense
of going back to
get discrete time,
he can't put this on a computer.
Okay. So, what's going to
happen is that somehow
this differential equation
cannot be discretized stably.
Okay. So, that's now a mystery,
leads to a year
ago was a mystery.
Why can't we discretize
the dynamics when we're using
these fast clocks or
overly fast clocks?
We know we can't,
because I think you
discretize that he'd
be the oracle rate.
Can't do that.
Right. What happens when
we write a clock speed
when we can
discretize and then how
did we describe the
one that is possible.
Alright, so I have
some theorems on this.
They're not completely done in
the sense I'd like necessary
and sufficient conditions,
these are the mostly
sufficient, right?
But, they are all
coming out of the
prospective known as symplectic
integrators or
symplectic geometry.
How many of you know about
that already? Yeah, one.
I hope you know man, better.
How many of you know
what the FFT is?
Yeah, so it's amazing.
Somebody gives you way more
important than the FFT.
Yeah, so I'm going to say
a little bit about what it is,
I think I have a slide
on. Yes, here it is.
So, this is a very important
area mathematics
departments or have
symplectic geometries and then
every mathematic department
has some of them.
It came from the late 1800s
when people like Hamilton,
Jacobi, and Poincare', and
some of those luminaries.
We're asking very interesting
question, they said,
"We've got a whole bunch
of differential equations
lying around from physics like,
Maxwell's equations,
Newton's equations,
fluid flow and so on."
We know that there are not
just differential equations,
they have some laws that if
I flow along the exact flow,
I conserve like, energy or
momentum or volumes at this pace.
This is before computers,
were they were asking
the following question,
what if we have to discretize
this to get an actual algorithm,
we're now going to
hop along the flow
and not quite along the flow.
We'll be a little bit off, right?
But, is there a way to do
that approximately such
that you exactly still
conserve the laws of physics,
you conserve the momentum
and the energy and all,
as you do this approximate path.
It's amazing quite
that they asked
this question and
they answered it.
So, this area seems like
integration does this,
and so I've spent a year
reading all about this.
Here's the basic
short version of this
that normally you think
of a vector field,
a differential equation
of the vector field.
I'm moving along, I'm at a point,
vector is leading that point
and I follow that
vector a little bit,
then I got the next vector
and I stitch this long.
Symplectic integration has
different perspective,
it says at any given point,
there's a triple of
vectors and that defines
a little volume element and
as I move along the flow,
that volume that will shear.
But, I want the actual volume
stays constant.
Can I do that? Well, the
volumes that little determinates
and alternating form.
So, I have now alternating
forms on a manifold,
and Poincare' already
worked on that.
Turns out you can do it, you can
exactly conserve
these little volume elements
and the integrators that do
this are not
Runge-Kutta or Euler,
or whatever, they are a mixture
of implicit and explicit.
So, it's implicit
Runge-Kutta explicit.
If you do one or the other,
you're not symplectic,
but if you mix them in
a particular way,
you are symplectic.
Meaning, that you can
serve these quantities.
Now, this seems pretty far away
from acceleration and
certainly very far
away from AI, but it's not.
So, when you conserve
these quantities,
an additional benefit is
that a bunch of
higher-order terms vanish.
Because, it's symmetries
are being conserved.
That means you can
move much faster.
You can take
much bigger step-sizes
and that's the connection
to acceleration.
Take much faster step size,
even optimal size
steps, all right?
So, long story short,
now there's a
mathematical recipe that
starts from an
optimization problem,
and writes down
the Bregman Lagrangian.
Now, we're going to go into
the Hamiltonian formalism
which is the easier way
to develop symplectic
integrators,
sort of the standard
physics recipe.
You take a Lagrange, you
do the Legendre transform,
conju-duality goes
over to Hamiltonian.
This Hamiltonian is time varying.
We want to get a time-invariant,
one because that's
the easiest way to
develop symplectic integrators.
So, we do a standard procedure
called "lifting".
We introduce a time variable
and its conjugate dual,
put them in as
explicit state variables.
Now, we're on a space in which
the Hamiltonian is
time-invariant,
and you just run a symplectic
integrator on that off the shelf.
People in real physics that's
similar to cosmos or proteins,
whatever, only use
symplectic integrators.
They do not use anything else.
So, there are
standard software or
standard methodology
for doing this.
Okay, so let me show you
a picture of doing this.
This is just a particular
high dimensional
optimization problem,
particular function.
We didn't have to think at all.
We simply plugged
in the function,
Euler-Lagrange equation,
Hamiltonian selecting her,
and putting it on a computer,
and you see it converges.
It is oscillating.
It goes up and down as
predicted and we are
achieving an oracle rate.
Okay.
If I didn't want to spend
much more time on this,
but if I put Nesterov
next to this,
Nesterov roughly is the same.
It has a phase near the
end which it goes
a little faster,
which I could talk more
about if you are interested.
But now, if you turn
up the step size,
Nesterov goes unstable,
and this thing stay stable
down to a factor of about 10.
We can get a 10 wall-clock
improvement with this algorithm.
Okay. Now, I'm going to go
back to work with Chi again.
Now that we have
some ingredients,
we can put these
together. Yeah, please.
>> You mentioned, so implicit
and explicit, things.
>> Yeah.
>> So, computationally if you
should confuse [inaudible].
>> Yeah. So, you do
what's called splitting.
You take this big
old Hamiltonian,
you split it into pieces,
and you make sure
the implicit part is easy to do.
Typically, this what's called
the "leapfrog integrator" with
the implicit part is
actually not so complicated.
But, absolutely if
you split wrong,
you can have the implicit part
be a load, okay?
But, it's part of
future research to kind of
characterize cases where
that's not the problem.
Okay. So, I'm going to try to
finish up here in a
couple of minutes,
sliding into the optima here.
So, an open problem has
been that acceleration
helped you get
past saddle points.
I mentioned that before.
Taking this continuous
time presparody
is Hamiltonian
presparody if you will,
helps fill the answer
this question.
Okay, so let's kind
of skip a little bit.
These are some slides I actually
borrowed from Chi, here.
Let me just skip over this.
Okay, we're going
to be interested in
this setting and we've talked
about already its smoothness for
gradient, smoothness for Hessian.
We want to bring in
acceleration now,
and hit second order
stationary points.
So, setup is the same as before.
Here is an algorithm that you
can analyze it basically,
just I don't want
to get any details.
Its gradient descent is
this perturbation as
well and it also is
an accelerated algorithm, okay.
It accelerates and perturbs.
Here is a theorem which
says that the rate
now goes down from
epsilon squared to epsilon
to the seven-fourths.
So, proof that
just pure acceleration
does help you to get
past saddle points.
The o-tilde again as
a polylogarithmic term in
dimension, so that
didn't go away.
Here is the Hamiltonian that
was used in
this particular paper.
It's actually
a simple lite version of
Hamiltonian and I won't
get into details,
but that was key in
getting the theorem here.
Then, last two slides,
now, let's start.
This is ongoing work,
is trying to bring
this into the world of
Markov chain Monte Carlo and
try to contribute there.
So, to do that, we're going to
study as well as work
with Xiang Cheng
and Peter Barlett and
Niladri Chatterji at Berkeley.
We're going to try
to accelerate now,
not just gradient flow
or gradient descent.
We're going to try to
accelerate diffusion
stochastic processes,
and sample like Markov chain
Monte Carlo does.
There had been negative
results on this sheet
because its diffusion
has got a lot of noise.
It's Brownian motion
and trying to
accelerate Brownian motion
is not so easy.
But, those results have been
on what's called overdamped
motion done in
the physics literature,
overdamped diffusion.
So, this is just that you take
the gradient and you
add Brownian motion.
It's like gradient descent,
but not just pure stochasticity,
it adds Brownian
motion directly to
the gradient, all right?
So, we've just seen that
these momentum kind of
methods are able to
go faster, all right?
So, what if we go to
a more momentum version
of Langevin, all right?
So, here it is. This
is classical Langevin.
This is stochastic differential
equation notation.
It just takes the gradient.
It goes down in as as
Brownian motion. All right.
We're going to look at an
underdamped Langevin where you
add Brownian motion to
the velocity and then,
you integrate the velocity.
So, the bad noise that
occurred by the Brownian motion
is getting filtered.
Okay, and here is my last slide.
So, there has been beautiful
work in France on analyzing,
finally kind of finite time,
convergence results for Langevin.
It goes as dimension over epsilon
squared and for underdamped,
our paper shows that if you
go all the way down from
epsilon squared to epsilon, okay.
Again, the proof here needs
this continuous time
Hamiltonian perspective to go.
Okay, I'm going to skip that.
Yeah, so I'm basically done.
I did want to give
my two matters is one,
a bit of publicity for
this project called Ray.
We have, on my list of
other topics to work on,
is a large, long list of things
that are kind of
engineering or systems,
computer system stuff and so,
part of my career the last
10 years has been investing
in heavy labs with
computer scientists who
are systems people,
not AI people, including
people like Ion Stoica and
Dave Patterson, and so on.
We've had several labs
now, the Amp Lab,
the Rise Lab with the Rad Lab
that had been
real success stories.
I would give
a separate talk on that.
Just let me note that Spark
came out of this lab,
kind of the interaction
between machine
learning people and
systems people.
We have a new project called Ray,
which is kind of Spark for
Reinforcement Learning.
Spark is a block
synchronous paradigm
where you parallelize,
and each parallel thread or
process has got to roughly
run the same amount of time.
If you do rollouts in
Reinforcement Learning
or stochastic search,
some rollouts take a long time
to decide it was a bad idea,
and others take very short time
to decide it was a bad idea.
So, you have this heterogeneous
workloads and Ray
attempts to or does
accommodate that.
So, here's the author list,
Philip Moritz and
Robert Nishihara,
our students working with me at
Berkeley, and then, Ion Stoica.
Let me just cut,
I want to just say this exists,
and I'm not going to
show, it's there
where I want to show.
It is an open source project,
and it has now seen contributors
throughout the world,
and you can now put
it on your laptop
within five minutes and
that be up and running it.
So, I'd like to
encourage people here or
systems minded to have
a look at what we're
doing with Ray.
It's pretty
interesting. So, that's
all I could pop up
to the top level,
but I think I've said
everything I want to say.
>> All right.
>> Naively asking about
Ray, is it that smart cast-
>> No. That was Spark.
Ray is basically
about smart scheduling.
>> I see.
>> You got to decide once
our little thread
processes really quickly.
So, you're doing
game search, your AlphaGo,
and you're going
down a game tree,
and you realize pretty quickly
that was a stupid idea.
So, the processes should been
liberated into something else.
So, you have
a dynamic flow graph,
and it was an act or
paradigm and you
decide intelligently
which new processor
to give another job.
Then you have a global
and local schedulers
interacting in
a fairly complex way.
So, there's a big dance
of scheduling going on.
There's objects store and
scheduling issues
behind the hood.
>> Okay, now you got
my first question.
Let's get this moving. Questions?
>> Yes.
>> [inaudible]
>> I can repeat
the question if that helps.
>> That will be easier for me.
Inactive. So, in
the Nesterov formulation,
I didn't see any structure or
geometry about the loss function.
So, does it apply to
all objective functions?
>> Nothing applies to
all objective functions.
So, yeah, there's
some constraints
on the objective function there,
that was always just for
convex, the Nesterov.
>> Yeah, so, even convex.
>> But, there's mirror descent
allows you to get a lot
of geometry into their,
the mirror descent
version, the same theory
applies to mirror descent.
But, going beyond that
to other kinds of
non-convex and
other loss functions,
you have to do some
problem-specific work on
that, that's going to be life.
That's why I will
always be employed.
You have to think about
your loss function,
you have to think about
the properties of
the loss function,
and you have to
exploit the structure
of that, and so on, so forth.
Our generic theorems
will guide you,
but they're not
going to just, it's
not going to be plug and
play for quite some time.
I remember Chris Meek
back in the back.
>> Can you give some information
on the [inaudible].
>> Yeah.
>> [inaudible] it's suitably
chosen, then you get results.
>> No, this is just a way
of formally what we mean
by a rate of convergence.
>> [inaudible] involve the
altercation of the radius for it?
>> Yeah, epsilon.
>> Or is it, [inaudible]
abbreviation involves size R.
What is the relationship between
R? What do you mean by R?
>> You want to try to say
it more cleanly than I can?
>> So, basically, just
take R to be roughly
epsilon, up to some allowed
vectors of epsilon.
Epsilon is the final algorithm
that you want to find.
>> This is more of
a meta-level observation
in the sense that
a bunch of techniques
that you mentioned
were in the continuous
time space and we have to
discretize it because of
our computer architectures.
>> Yeah.
>> So, do you think there's
enough motivation
for few of us to
start looking at computing
and the containers?
>> Analog.
>> Directly?
>> Yeah, I've been asked
that question before and
I actually believe it.
Yes. I liked
this symplectic approach
because it's a beautiful way
to discretize.
But there are
some real advantages to
working just purely
continuous time,
don't have to worry about
some of these issues,
there's stability issues
that are handled for you.
So, this is the first time
I've worked on something
where I feel like,
yeah, actually, I would like to
have a line on
my computer to do this.
I think it will be worldly
interesting to explore.
>> You have an analab next.
>> Really, an analab, yeah.
>> Getting on
the first part where you
spoke about importance of
thinking about markets.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm curious whether for
the optimization landscape,
you're also thinking about
more generalizations
like variance in equilibria.
>> Yeah, I've thought
about that and even
tried to work on that kind
of thing from time to time.
I am aware, for example,
of an interesting
literature of not
escaping saddle points but
going towards saddle points.
There's still actually
open problems
there of how fast
can you approach a saddle point
because the saddle point,
you'll gain theoretic optimum is
what you want to
be at, not avoid.
So, yeah, it's just like
the next 10 years of my career,
I guarantee there's
be a fair amount of,
more economic stuff,
and then I got, already
have some ideas.
But, that's what I tend
to do in life as I say
what I'm going to do and
then I just try to
work on it and hope
other people will teach me
things along the way
because I didn't.
I know very little about
serious economics math.
I just hope I can
learn it quickly.
They work with statistics
and differential equations,
so I should be ready to go.
But I know that MSR has got
a lot of people here and
I think that this is,
I think you might not
be aware of this,
but it's not just about
advertised placement.
That's not a big application
of economics and
machinery together.
To me, it is actually
the trillion dollar play of
how do you actually really,
and this load balancing problem
I alluded to is critical.
Machine learning people aren't
thinking about it at all.
They're thinking they're
just going to deploy things
and they're not thinking about
the universe scarcity out
there, it's not going to work.
In a narrow domain
like transportation,
yes, they'll do
dynamic programming
I'll send everybody
on the same route.
But it's a way
broader problem and that's,
if you use really any bidding
mechanism or economics there.
>> You got resources.
You could play medical system in
the world and influence in
the distribution statistics
that is equal to
the bright eye system
[inaudible] doesn't actually
know that, they consider this.
>> Yeah.
>> So, no question or comments.
Wait, what if let's
talk about at all about
[inaudible] around
the world now in cities.
>> Yeah.
>> I would also just
wait patiently.
There's always one hand that
would open the audience.
I'm waiting for your question
and my answer always was time.
Not enough people use Bing Maps
to make this a big deal.
But at Google, it must
be a big problem.
Google Maps with the directions
and over subscription
of [inaudible].
>> So, I have
one funny anecdote, too,
since you're telling
good funny anecdotes,
I want to try to top you,
which was that I was in China
now and I was giving this talk
about AI and
everyone's asking me,
is all the hype about AI true,
and I'll to try to stamp it down.
But they were pushing on well,
yeah, all your problems,
maybe it's going to take decades.
But, in pure human imitative AI,
were made such progress like they
could think about
natural English translation,
it's nearly solved, isn't it?
So, Doug Hofstadter wrote
a very nice article.
If you haven't seen The
Shallowness of Google Translate,
that if you haven't read
that, you should read that.
Everybody should be aware
that just getting to
90 or 95 percent does not
mean we are within
five percent of the answer.
We're way away from,
they'll give you good examples.
But anyway, on
the screen behind me,
there was supposed to
be a panel session
then one of the speakers
didn't make it,
and then it was on the screen
virtually behind us.
I won't name this person.
This person was going on about
AI and translation and
autonomous this and that,
and how translation, we're
not quite there yet,
but within ten years, we'll
definitely have done it.
There was an automatic
translation going on the screen.
I think it was so go,
I think it was
a Chinese thing and
it was transcription
and translation.
So, the speaker
said at some point,
"That's a red herring in AI.
Everyone know what
a red herring is?
Okay, a red herring is a fish,
a herring is a kind of fish,
and red herring, someone
bright knows the etymology
better than me.
Just means something, that
everyone's paying attention,
you shouldn't pay
attention, it's irrelevant.
That's a red herring.
Don't worry about it.
So, he says something,
I forget the topic,
is a red herring in AI.
The translation came out was,
"That's a red hair in his eye."
>> Yeah. This a
productive session
we've had here about
the whole advances in AI.
What was it [inaudible] there was
a comment that some
of these advances are
like the excitement that
a monkey feels running up
into a tree thinking
he or she getting
closer to the moon,
and this could be the wrong
fact or the wrong.
>> I heard that's
not the monkey part.
That's new elements.
Why is a monkey needed in
this particular metaphor?
>> It implies that the type
of thinking it's on.
>> I see.
>> Okay, any other question?